[Musique]
le monde
de l'année
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout 8 voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 28 juin un goût
amer dans les rangs de la classe
politique au lendemain d'un deuxième
dimanche déserté par les électeurs c'est
lé président sortant reste à la tête des
régions la république en marche et le
rassemblement national sont les grands
perdants du scrutin
après un vote local 100 patients place
lors izon flou de 2022
christian jacob annonceurs lui que le
candidat des républicains à la
présidentielle sera connu en novembre
[Musique]
démission aujourd'hui du premier
ministre suédois stefan lofven une
décision qui intervient deux semaines
après le vote de la motion de défiance
une première dans le pays
le président du parlement aura la lourde
tâche de trouver un nouveau chef du
gouvernement dans les prochains jours
mais celui que l'on surnomme le social
on de droite n'a pas pour autant fait
ses adieux au pouvoir
les combats font rage dans le nord du
yémen une centaine de morts dénombrés en
trois jours dans la province de marib
théâtre d'une guerre entre l'armée et
les rebelles houthi une situation dont
pâtissent des millions de civils
déplacés dans le pays dans un conflit
qui perdure malgré les appels au
cessez-le-feu des nations unies
[Musique]
rencontre furtive donc ce matin entre le
président de la république emmanuel
macron et le président réélu des hauts
de france xavier bertrand adoue et dans
le nord pour des déplacements aux airs
de campagne présidentielle il faut dire
que tout semble désormais ouverts ou en
2022 au lendemain d'un scrutin d'une
nouvelle fois déserté par les électeurs
français
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite katia technique en direct de
l'elysée bonsoir katia que retenir don
de ce deuxième tour des régionales
[Musique]
et bien stéphanie c'est l'élection du
statu quo à la carte politique n'a pas
changé avec la prime aux sortants ou la
prime au travail accompli on peut le
voir comme ça encore la prime à celui
dont le nom a été repéré alors seuls 67
mobiliser ce qui tenait vraiment à leur
candidat on peut noter vous le disais
deux choses des aveux appliquée infligé
au rassemblement national et à la
république en marche qui n'ont pas pu
compter sur une base électorale forte
alors au sujet du rassemblement national
marine le pen n'a pas déplacé ses
électeurs elle n'a pas réussi à prendre
une région avec l'échec en paca de
thierry mariani il ya eu également une
défaite historique dans les hauts de
france
et pourtant les sondages précédant le
premier jour estimé que le rassemblement
national pourrait briguer six régions
sur les 13 de métropole alors autre
chose à noter évidemment un revers pour
la république en marche c'est presque
pire ils n'ont réussi à totaliser que 7%
des suffrages au niveau national avec
leur liste commune avec le modem
et c'est christophe castaner l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur qui en parle le
mieux il a reconnu que le bilan était
mauvais il a aussi reconnu que les
représentants de la république en marche
avait du mal avec un enracinement local
alors à noter toutefois le plébiscite
d'une socialiste carole delga la mieux
réélu 57 7% en occitanie elle a été
décrite comme un bourreau de travail qui
se déplaçait énormément sur le
territoire qui connaissait ses dossiers
qu'ils savaient se mettre en avant se
faire connaître et bien cela a payé dans
les urnes et autre chose à noter au
niveau des écologies s'ils n'ont pas
gagné deux régions en revanche c'est une
estimation leur nombre de conseillers
régionaux pourrait être multiplié par
trois thiam malgré les efforts un des
candidats les électeurs n'étaient pas
franchement au rendez vous c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire
oui en effet puisque déjà au premier
tour il y avait une pléthore de listes
qui pouvait appeler chaque électeur
parce qu'il y avait de très nombreuses
sensibilités politiques représentés et
bien ils ne se sont pas déplacés pas
plus au second tour puisque et à ce
record historique de 66 % d'abstention
chez les jeunes c'est pire que dans la
tranche des 18 34 ans il ya eu 79 %
d'abstention je vous propose d'écouter
jean castex le premier ministre qui a
réagi et 7 abstentions
donc nous prenons évidemment cette
situation tout à fait au sérieux
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
d'ailleurs annoncé mardi dernier des
initiatives en ce sens démocratie
fonctionne au mieux ma jambe pro je
profite du fait que jean castex se soit
exprimée pour annoncer qu emmanuel
macron a dit qu'il ne serait pas
remplacé dans les prochains mois en tout
cas pour revenir aux élections pourquoi
cette abstention est ce que c'est parce
que j'avais moins jeunes d'ailleurs
n'ont pas compris les enjeux du scrutin
la région à diverses compétences très
importantes comme les transports
également le sport les lycées
l'aménagement du territoire et en fait
c'est évidemment important et pourtant
les absentionnistes qu'on peut
interroger disque par exemple ça ne sert
à rien ça ça précisément à ce que je
viens de dire ou alors les politiques
tous les mêmes alors que là il ne s'agit
pas d'élire des politiques stars mais
réellement des élus de terrain
on ne peut pas dire non plus que le
gouvernement ait fait particulièrement
la promotion de ces élections un ces
derniers mois et puis d'une autre
manière on va je voudrais aborder le
traitement médiatique des débats il y en
a eu 2 par exemple pour l'île de france
au premier tour les têtes de listes les
sept têtes de liste ont eu environ 20
minutes
s'exprimer sur lci second tour les
quatre têtes de liste en revue environ
25 minutes pour s'exprimer il était
interrompu toutes les deux minutes par
les présentateurs qui leur disaient vite
vite vite on n'a pas le temps c'est pas
vraiment faire honneur un président de
région que de présenter les débats comme
cela ouais katia il y a également eu les
dysfonctionnements pour la diffusion de
la propagande des candidats
[Musique]
oui absolument c'est fanny ce fameux pas
le prestataire adrexo chargé de la
propagande de 50 départements 51
départements pardon sur les sept régions
il n'avait pas rempli ses obligations au
premier tour et bien pour le second tour
ça s'est renouvelée juste une
information sur le premier tour c'était
9% des plis électoraux qui n'avait pas
été distribués alors pour le second tour
la poste a été appelé à la rescousse à
la livre et 5 millions de plis
électoraux mais il ya toujours eu des
couacs 1 sur toute la chaîne allant de
la logistique à la distribution lors
l'entreprise adrexo va être auditionné
par la commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale mardi
gérald darmanin lui a déjà été
auditionné pour le même sujet au sénat
en tout cas c'est encore un fiasco pour
l'état 1 concernant cette mission de
prestations ils ont choisi un
prestataire privé réduisant la part du
public mais qui a finalement été appelé
à la rescousse et merci cattier ap
compte en direct de l'elysée et ce sont
donc 15 à 20 millions d'électeurs qui se
sont abstenus dimanche des électeurs que
chaque candidat à la présidentielle va
sans doute vouloir aller chercher alors
quels enseignements peut-on tirer de ce
scrutin en vue évidemment de 2022 les
cartes sont totalement rebattues quid du
fameux duels souvent annoncée entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec et
laurent jacot bélie porte parole du
rassemblement national vous étiez
candidat laurent jacobellis tête de
liste et rennes dans le grand-est
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce soir daniele car vice
président hu dei de la région de france
candidat aux régionales sur la liste de
xavier bertrand dans l'oise vous avez
vous célébrer sa victoire hier soir et
vous nous accompagner lors de ce
décryptage merci à vous également d'être
avec nous alexis pour les enfants qu'on
connaît très bien ici notre
éditorialiste bonsoir alexis alors 24
heures après les résultats de ce premier
tour de ce deuxième tour même projection
sur la présidentielle le duel macron le
pen n'est plus si inéluctable que ça
c'est le premier enseignement que l'on
peut tirer tout ce que tu alexis poulain
oui clairement on a vu que là dans les
urnes
même si 66% abstention c'est beaucoup
pour en tirer des conclusions mais le
binôme vendus par les sondeurs un
rassemblement national et la république
en marche et loin derrière
comparé aux formations traditionnelles
alors il y avait une prime aux sortants
évidemment dans ces régionales
on voit que les régions ont très peu
changé ce qui expliquerait sans doute
ses résultats mais il ya quand même
quelque chose du déficit de campagne de
publicité autour de ces élections aux
dates d'adrexo le fait qu' on en a très
peu parlé au premier tour et puis malgré
la semaine d'entre deux tours où les
appareils ont appelé à voter où
finalement les médias on essaie de
rattraper le temps perdu ça n'a pas
suffi on a vu que l'abstention restait
au très haut
soit parce que on ne comprenait pas
finalement les enjeux de serre et les
élections régionales soit parce que l'on
choisisse est aussi politiquement de ne
pas voter parce que l'offre politique
semble ne pas répondre aussi à une
certaine demande alors il ya une vraie
question pourquoi on continue encore
avec des sondages de sortir des urnes et
le dimanche soir et le lundi à revendre
le duel macron le pen alors que à un an
des élections
les choses sont encore très mouvante et
peuvent tout à fait changer
reste à voir ce qu'il en sera ces
résultats des régionales handicap
certains candidats et pourtant on pousse
d'autres c'est le cas de xavier bertrand
qui lui avait misé beaucoup sur ces
régionales pour la suite des opérations
puisqu'il est
dida aussi à l'élection de 2022
effectivement à droite il ya surtout
vous l'avais dit à xavier bertrand qui
compte bien installer le match avec
emmanuel macron dès hier d'ailleurs un
président réélu dans les hauts de france
a lancé sa campagne présidentielle
regardez avant de gâcher alors on
écoutera xavier bertrand plus tard alors
je vais vous le dire je vais faire et
xavier bertrand que vous ayez voté ou
pas je vous le dis ce soir nous avons
besoin de vous notre nation a besoin de
vous de chacun d'entre vous de votre
patriotisme de votre volonté farouche de
voir la france retrouver le premier rang
un discours au quasi de deux campagnes
un daniel leca xavier bertrand veut
prendre de vitesse ses rivaux à droite
mais dévie pécresse et laurent wauquiez
tout cas ce qu'on peut jeu qu'on peut
dire c'est que gilles bertrand une
mairie de la clarté a le mérite de la
transparence
certains estimé que cette démarche qui
consistait à assumer de lier le résultat
d'élections régionales à une potentielle
l'élection présidentielle était
malhonnête ce résultat le résultat des
urnes à prouver qu'au contraire il y
avait une prime à la clarté prime à la
transparence une prime à la vérité et
xavier bertrand a toujours dit que il
continuerait à s'engager pour sa région
mais que sa réussite dans sa région
serait une sorte de démonstration de sa
capacité à faire reculer le front
national et a présenté d'alternative
crédible
il l'a montré dans cette campagne
régionale il l'a montré hier soir lors
de l'annoncé des résultats
et je crois que dans les semaines qui
viennent il aura à coeur de démontrer
qu'il est le seul à pouvoir faire
reculer le front national concrètement
par l'action et par les résultats
le rassemblement national et lui on l'a
dit on le sait de manière générale très
en dessous de ce qu avait annoncé des
instituts de sondages aucune région
remporter on s'est planté a dit
clairement gilbert collard au député
reynès ce matin laurent jacot bélie
votre sentiment personnel se soient
remerciés déjà d'être avec no 1 c
un échec de marine le pen et de sa
stratégie notamment de fameux
dédiabolisation on en a beaucoup parlé
dans le dans les commentaires
aujourd'hui sept lits d'équilibriste à
trouver qui n'est pas évidente non
écoutez je ne le crois pas et moi
j'admire tout ce qui arrive à tirer des
conclusions statistiques ou politique
d'un aussi faible et santi
échantillonnage des lecteurs moi je
regrette cette abstention mais trois
français sur dix seulement sont allés
voter des présidents de région
aujourd'hui ont été élus entre 11 et 15
% des inscrits c'est très peu
c'est très faible et très honnêtement
celui qui arrive à lire dans le marc de
café à partir d'aussi peu de votants et
bien il est très fort moi je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas le faire et comme les
gens ne sont pas allés voter bien
malheureusement il y a eu une surprime
au sortant parce que le sortant
et bien c'est celui qui tient les
réseaux souvent c'est celui qui tient la
presse quotidienne régionale
c'est lui qui tient un certain nombre de
maires et donc ils agitent ces réseaux
il a un minimum de socle de votants et
on le voit bien d'ailleurs la totalité
des régions ont reconduit leur président
sortant les alertes ont conquis aucune
région alors ils font un peu les
matamores parce qu'il était agonisant
ils ont repris un peu de souffle mais
honnêtement rien rien n'indique qu'il y
à un engouement pour monsieur bertrand
madame truc où monsieur y
simplement on a reconduit les sortants
je pense que c'est la seule conclusion
qu'on peut tirer avec une autre
conclusion quand même c'est que l'état
aujourd'hui est incapable d'organiser
des élections
incapable de distribuer les bons
bulletins de vote dans la bonne région
mois des bulletins avec mon nom du grand
est ont été distribués en bourgogne
franche comté est ce que vous trouvez ça
raisonnable et puis le président de la
république a sa part de responsabilité
au lendemain du premier tour où il y
avait déjà cet échec démocratique qui
était ce fort taux d'abstention
le président de la république n'est pas
intervenu n'a pas appelé au sursaut la
seule personne avec laquelle il a trouvé
bon de s'entretenir c'est justin bieber
vous le voyez je pense que l'état ne
vous
et pas de participation massive
probablement parce qu'il avait prévu la
déculottée 7 % pour le parti du
président de la république c'est à dire
que le président de la république réunit
ce soir 2 3 % des inscrits emmanuel
macron restera comme monsieur 2% mais je
pense qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin
dans les conclusions un robert ménard
entre collègues un maire de béziers à
cette petite idée sur la question je
vous propose d'écouter robert ménard
elle la déroute de l air eux-mêmes et
historiques en dehors du phénomène
macron ce mouvement est une coquille
vide alors effectivement françois
patriat alexis poulain le sénateur la
reine avait estimé lui même que que la
république en marche était devenu un
parti de cliqueurs et pas de militants
ça rejoint cette idée de coquille vide
évoquée par robert ménard oui tout à
fait enfin on le on le constate élection
après élection la république en marche
ça a été une plate forme qui a permis à
aimer les mâcon de se présenter en 2017
et deux volets d'une certaine façon
l'élection puisqu'il arrivait sans parti
avec ce mouvement qu'il a pu monter
grâce à un financement international et
un support aussi médias une campagne
média assez incroyable il a pu gagner
mais en réalité ce parti ne s'est jamais
transformé en partie à la fois les
militants de la première heure qui ont
été très tôt déçu de voir que la
promesse de partie horizontale ou où
chaque habit comptes n'existaient pas il
y avait une structure pyramidale où tout
était contrôlé depuis l'appareil du
parti
et puis finalement très peu de militants
et très peu d'élus municipal
élections régionales maintenant on voit
bien que c'est un parti qui n'existe pas
parce que il est créé de toutes pièces
telles frankenstein d'un peu de l air
d'un peu du ps d' un peu du modem de lui
des ide un peu tout le monde pour dire
bon bah qu'est ce qui soude tout ça
c'était le programme enfin le projet
plutôt demeurer le maquereau et donc le
fait de une promesse de marocains de
postes de sièges
en réalité le projet on le voit il
arrive à terme c'est la casse de la
république sociale la réforme des
retraites la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
très peu finalement pour résoudre les
inégalités un cafouillage total dans
l'éducation nationale maintenant à
l'intérieur un cafouillage énorme sur
l'organisation d'élections bref un bilan
qui va être difficile à défendre et on
voit bien que certains qui avaient cette
étiquette la république en marche
commence à s'en séparer parce qu'il voit
qu'elle est perdante et ils veulent
maintenant dissoudre la public en marche
dans une une sorte de maison commune
pour refaire une plateforme pour refaire
un coup comme en 2017 mais c'est
impossible puisque maintenant mln macro
est connue de tous les français
il a un bilan à défendre est il un parti
qui est en train de s'écrouler sur lui
même faute de militants faute aussi
d'élus donc au delà du parti hors sol 1
qui existe simplement grâce à de
nombreux députés à l'assemblée nationale
c'est un parti qui n'existe pas sauf
dans les médias dans les sondages et
parce qu'il est parti du président alors
à droite on le sait depuis ce soir un
candidat sera annoncé en novembre
c'est ce qu'a dit le patron des
républicains ce soir ce matin même
christian jacob
est-ce qu'il faut daniel leca une
primaire à droite en 2016 on n'a pas que
des bons souvenirs de la primaire à
droite 1 moi j'allais dire que ces
sujets qui sont important qui nécessite
un consensus des différentes formations
politiques qui se reconnaissent comme
étant à droite pour identifier le bon
candidat au fonds n'intéresse pas les
français et je crains que
malheureusement si on continue à
s'enfermer dans un discours d'appareils
d'apparatchiks conflit par tourner en
rond et au final nous serions pas
surpris si assez tôt de m
avec ces majeurs pour remporter une
présidence
cette stratégie on va vous le savez non
mais l'unité se fera autour de la
capacité d'un homme ou d'une femme a
rassemblé le son camp et à rassembler le
plus largement possible et très
objectivement quand j'entends le front
national qui se met toujours en position
de commentateurs et qui explique que la
faute des l'abstention la faute de leurs
piètres résultats c'est la faute des
autres
c'est la faute globalement du système
c'est la faute aux à l'incapacité de
l'état à organiser l'élection
enfin la réalité ce qu'a démontré cette
élection régionale secte et qu'il y
avait une prime à ceux qui font à ce
qu'ils agissent à ceux qui changent le
quotidien et je crois que de la même
manière pour l'élection présidentielle
il va y avoir une remobilisation parce
que et c'est regrettable des français
considèrent que l'élection
présidentielle c'est l'alpha et l'oméga
de la vie politique française c'est un
vrai problème parce que les
collectivités locales ont un vrai rôle
pour le quotidien des gens et c'est à
nous politiques de le démontrer mais je
crois que lors de la mobilisation pour
l'élection présidentielle
ça se jouera sur la capacité du candidat
ou de la candidate a montré qu'il a un
projet qu'il est capable de le porter et
ensuite de le mettre en oeuvre
concrètement si on a aujourd'hui des
français qui se détournent des urnes
c'est parce que des politiques ont
pendant trop longtemps et est pardon à
mes des vendeurs de rêves à chaque
élection présidentielle on a
l'impression que par une baguette
magique on va changer absolument tout on
sait qu'aujourd'hui cette cette vision
là ne tient plus les français n'y
croient plus donc il faut un candidat
qui sait gérer qui a démontré sa
capacité à au fond mené des réformes
importantes à conduire des politiques
publiques et je crois que ça va partir
des territoires et c'est ça le vrai
changement
je crois que même si nous avons eu là un
taux de participation assez faible
l'élection présidentielle sera le moment
de montrer que le changement viendra par
la capacité à mener les changements à
mener les réformes et donc par la
capacité de d'une certaine manière à
s'appuyer sur une expérience qui viendra
du local des collectivités locales le
maire est aujourd'hui l'homme politique
le plus populaire chez les français
pourquoi parce que on voit ce qu'il fait
on voit les résultats et ce café xavier
bertrand dans la région d autres france
c'est cela c'est à dire mener des
politiques concrètes qui changeait le
quotidien alors le front national ici
beaucoup moqué de nos mesures s'est
beaucoup moqué de l'ensemble des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
pour aider ceux qui cherchent et du
travail notamment
mais au fond c'est ça qui a changé le
quotidien et c'était aussi une
récompense qui a été qui a été donnée à
xavier bertrand
même si oui le niveau d'abstention doit
nous inquiéter et doit impliquer une
mobilisation de toutes et de tous y
compris des politiques et surtout des
politiques qui doivent changer de
logiciel et c'est urgent laurent jacot
m'aider quand vous écoutez à daniel
l'écart vous fait quand même votre
examen de conscience au nom non mais
d'abord je trouve ça touchant d'avoir le
président du fan-club de xavier bertrand
ce soir est de voir que cette passion
l'aveuglent je vois aussi que le seul
programme de xavier bertrand semble être
de combattre le rassemblement national
il voulait je crois ni cassé la mâchoire
quel bel exemple de démocratie
et bien qu'ils construisent un programme
avant mais c'est peut-être pas la peine
puisque son programme on le connaît
c'est le même que monsieur macro on les
a vus ce matin la main dans la main
tenir le même discours faire les mêmes
mimiques employé les mêmes mots c'est
finalement le même produit dans un
emballage différents et nous verrons
bien ce que décideront les français je
crois qu'on a bien compris que
aujourd'hui face à cette mondialisation
face à cette casse sociale face à cette
immigration massive et cette insécurité
ce ne sont pas les bertrand les pécresse
ou autres maquereaux compatibles qui
feront la différence c'est une vraie
force d'alternance et je crois qu'on
sommes aujourd'hui les seuls à
représenter que marine le pen et le
rassemblement national
la preuve l'ami de monsieur bertrand ce
soir vous le voyez n'a comme autre
projet que de nouveaux barrer la route
ce qui veut bien dire finalement que ces
routes nous sont ouvertes
laurent jacques aubé dit daniel ek a
parlé d'incarnation tout à l'heure et
que ça se ferait naturellement en tout
cas à droite vous ça va se faire aussi
naturellement
que c'était prévu marine le pen
forcément incarnera les couleurs du r n
en 2022 est ce que c'est toujours aussi
acquis que ça aujourd'hui c'est tout à
fait clair nous nous avons la chance
d'avoir une candidate naturelle qui est
marine le pen qui porte le projet depuis
longtemps qui travaillent avec les
équipes qui construit un vrai plan
stratégique je dirais pour la france pas
seulement des années à venir mais de
2030 2040 2050
et puis un vrai projet alternatif au
projet actuel le projet de macron mais
qui n'est pas que le projet de macron
qui est le projet d'une partie dlr d'une
partie du ps est évidemment du centre et
nous verrons bien nous verrons bien qui
sera en compétition c'est une
compétition ouverte c'est beau la
démocratie
mais nous au moins nous savons qui va
porter nos couleurs il n'y aura pas de
guerre d'ego ce qui est une bonne chose
quand on voit le combat de coqs qui
commence à avoir lieu à droite sur la
base de résultats électoraux donc qu'il
ferait mieux de penser qu'ils sont tout
à fait relatif vu le nombre d'électeurs
en tout cas marine le pen sera notre
candidate et croyez-moi elle fera
l'union autour d'elle elle excite poule
est un candidat naturel évidemment la
république en marche à emmanuel macron
s'exprimera en juillet sur le cap de la
fin de son mandat mais vu des scores à
ces élections régionales est ce que
c'est si évident à ce qu emmanuel macron
doit se représenter ou est ce qui serait
bien inspiré de laisser sa place comme
l'avait fait françois hollande à
l'époque alors lui n'est pas parti pour
laisser sa place
emmanuel macron puisqu'il suit
finalement un déroulé peu importe les
résultats des élections intermédiaires
peu importe aussi le chambardement des
horloges un même si les horloges sont
déréglés lui continue s'étaient tous
france aujourd'hui il était à douai ce
matin il se met en scène encore de
manière systématique avec cette
pérégrination en france pour montrer
qu'il est quand même connecté avec les
populations même si ce n'est pas du tout
le cas donc on voit bien qu'il cherche
quand même à faire quelque chose et puis
il ya ce discours du 14 juillet qui est
annoncé comme un grand discours de la
refondation
on entend maintenant des bruits de
couloir sur la réunion du parlement à
versailles pour annoncer on ne sait pas
quoi
et puis la fameuse réforme des retraites
épineuse et et fameuse réforme des
retraites
est ce qu'il faut faire une blitz
réforme pendant l'été est ce qu'il faut
temporiser attendre là emmanuel macron
devra trancher mais on voit que pour lui
ça va être très compliqué de se
présenter en 2022 parce qu'il aura un
bilan difficile à défendre
puis parce que le en même temps ne
fonctionne plus on l'a vu très récemment
avec ses ministres qui se tient plus du
tout d'un côté du pont mory team is la
justice et de l'autre gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur qui n'ont rien à
faire ensemble dans un gouvernement
ça commence à se voir donc le en même
temps est fini et même macron va devoir
trancher y compris sur son projet 2022
s'il se présente il ne peut plus se
présenter sur le en même temps il donne
il doit choisir d'être candidat de
droite
ou alors candidat d'une
social-démocratie finissant à une sorte
de ps agonisant puisque remarche a été
fondée d'abord sur le ps avant de
devenir un mouvement qui est allé glaner
aller chercher à droite
or les élèves ont repris du poil de la
bête comme vous le disiez grâce à ces
régionales avec maintenant vous allez
bertrand qui caracole en tête mais
valérie pécresse qui a des idées laurent
wauquiez aussi qui est resté très
silencieux en ce début d'année mais qui
sans doute maintenant on va prendre la
parole et accélérer et puis d'autres qui
vont essayer aussi de voir comment
organiser
la maison les républicains pour aller à
la conquête du pouvoir parce qu'elle m'a
qu'on semble très affaibli donc je ne
crois pas qu'il fera comme françois
hollande arrêté et laisser la politesse
à par exemple sont anciens premiers
ministres edouard philippe qui est au
havre il pourrait aller jusqu'au bout
mais ça va être néanmoins très difficile
pour lui de refaire le coup de 2010 est
parce qu il est maintenant président
sortant et que comme je le disais son
bilan est très mitigé
merci en tout cas tous les trois lexsi
poulain daniel leca jus de l'orangé
comédie d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage merci à vous dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous évoquons
la démission du premier ministre suédois
une semaine après avoir été renversée
par un vote de défiance et puis nous
irons au yémen où de violents combats
opposent forces gouvernementales et
rebelles houthi dans l'ouest du pays
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers ont été compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rex it
le vrai sujet c'est celui de faire
dialoguer les douaniers français les
poignées britannique est ce qui
m'inquiète dans le bric side c'est par
le prêt que si c'est la bureaucratie du
plexi comment ça va se passer par
exemple pour l'été qui arrive la côte
d'azur verra peu ou pas d'anglais je
suspecte effectivement le gouvernement
britannique d'essayer de convaincre les
britanniques de rester en grande
bretagne pour faciliter la relance de
l'économie britannique par rapport à la
crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
mais
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique nos une
vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la rojita le
problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement reste que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les production de
vaccins ou et le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup danger sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
important on sait que le nigeria affirme
qu'il élabore son propre vaccin contre
le coc u19 pour en finir avec justement
la dépendance vis-à-vis des laboratoires
à l'étranger que ce soit le sénégal le
nigeria l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener la générale de la santé
publique au toc des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé oms
ep
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
20h38 bienvenue en direct sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez c'est officiel le
premier ministre suédois stefan levens à
démissionner une décision qui intervient
une semaine après le vote de la motion
de défiance par le parlement suédois ses
fans la veine avait alors deux
possibilités devant lui organiser des
élections anticipées ou partir c'est
finalement donc la deuxième option qu'il
a choisi le président du parlement aura
la lourde tâche de trouver un nouveau
chef du gouvernement dans les prochains
jours et à un an des élections
habituelles
compte tenu de la situation
extraordinaire dans laquelle se trouve
le pays avec une pandémie en cours et
les défis particuliers qu'elle poserait
des élections anticipées ne sont pas ce
qu'il ya de mieux pour la suède
sur cette base j'ai demandé au président
du parlement de me démettre de mes
fonctions de premier ministre est prêt
pour en parler nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir provencher
si d'être avec nous sur rt france cette
crise politique en suède
pour bien comprendre quelle en est la
cause au fond du gosier une cause
institutionnelle et les coûts ce qui
tient à la situation du logement soit la
cause institutionnelle c'est que un
parti d'extrême gauche à la gauche les
sociaux démocrates est apparue et avec à
sa tête maintenant une femme très
médiatique qui veut sa place dans la lah
dans la vie politique suédoise et puis à
l'extrême droite un parti qui est
surtout caractérisée par son sac
sinophobie et par sa volonté de lutter
contre toute immigration qui fait des
scores importants dans les sondages et
qui par conséquent gagne en importance
et il se trouve que ces deux partis
extraits des textes des deux extrêmes se
sont combinés au combiné leurs actions
pour faire chuter le gouvernement de
monsieur nouvelle alors bien sûr il y
avait en embuscade
le parti de droite traditionnel
le parti libéral qui dans le chef a dit
au même moment que dans le fond il
faudrait maintenant passer un à une
alternance avec un premier ministre de
droite puisque ça fait sept ans que
monsieur levens et premier ministre et
qu'il représente la gauche sociale
démocrate alors le deuxième raison c'est
évidemment la raison de fond c'est la
politique de logement et se trouve que
les loyers en suède sont bloqués ou
presque bloquée depuis 1940 ils sont en
tout cas administrés et que ceux ci a
deux conséquences
une pénurie de logements dans les
grandes villes il faut attendre une
dizaine d'années avant d'avoir accès à
un logement à prix régulier et puis
bien entendu ça aussi comme deuxième
conséquence de fait que ceux qui ont la
chance d'avoir un de ces logements à
prix régulés sont fortement tenté de le
soulever à un prix beaucoup plus élevé
par conséquent des dysfonctionnements
importants dans la politique du logement
et comme il l'avait promis aux partis de
droite au parti libéral monsieur levens
a donc proposé une loi qui permettrait
de libéraliser les loyers des nouveaux
logements donc seulement des nouveaux
logements ce qui est une réforme assez
limité puisque dans un premier temps -
ça ne toucherait pas les anciens
logements alors c'est sur ce sujet que
la présidente du parti d'extrême gauche
a dit que c'était tout à fait
inacceptable et que par conséquent elles
voteraient la motion de censure qui
étaient mises sur la table du parlement
pour d'autres raisons par le parti
d'extrême droite comme l'enjeu maison
que va-t-il se passer maintenant en
suède
et bien comme vous l'avez dit dans votre
sujet maintenant c'est le président du
parlement qui a la main et qui doit
trouver un nouveau premier ministre
susceptible de réunir 175 voix c'est à
dire la majorité du parlement et il a
pour ce faire
là le devoir de consulter bien sûr tous
les partis y compris d'ailleurs le
premier ministre sortant qui expédie les
affaires courantes et qui pourrait lui
aussi être chargé à nouveau de former un
gouvernement mais aussi d'essayer de
trouver des combinaisons qui assurent
ses 175 voix il a pour ce faire quatre
possibilité de choisir un premier
ministre successivement il a donc droit
à quatre essais et s'il n'y arrive pas
eh bien à ce moment là évidemment la
dissolution est inévitable alors cette
dissolution sera un petit peu insolite
parce que la constitution suédoise a une
particularité c'est qu'elle prévoit des
élections législatives à terme fixe et
donc il ya interne qui est prévue en
2022 2018 2022
et s'il devait y avoir une dissolution
et ben ça serait une élection
supplémentaire mais qu'il ne ferait pas
courir un nouveau délai de quatre ans à
druelle et saturn de la législature
n'aurait qu'un peu plus d'un an devant
elle
donc je pense que les parties vont tout
faire pour essayer d'éviter cela est
effectivement là une hypothèse qui
jusqu'à présent était repoussée par les
pales la plupart des partis de
gouvernement en suède et l'hypothèse
d'une alliance entre la droite classique
le centre et l'extrême droite
mais il n'est pas sûr encore une fois
que cette formule puisse fonctionner
elle la suède c'est un pays à part au
sein de l'europe on s'en est rendu
compte à plusieurs reprises pour quelles
raisons mais d'abord elle avait fait
route commune avec la grande-bretagne en
participant à l'association européenne
de libre échange et puis finalement peu
de temps après la la grande bretagne
après le royaume uni elle a décidé de
rejoindre l'union européenne
elle est entrée dans l'union européenne
en janvier 1995 et depuis cette époque
elle est un bon membre de l'union
européenne mais elle n'a pas voulu
rentrer dans le système monétaire unique
il n'a pas voulu prendre l'euro comme
monnaie unique elle a gardé sa monnaie
nationale
par ailleurs elle a des liens très
étroits traditionnelle avec les autres
pays nordiques
deux sont également membres de l'union
européenne
c'est la finlande et le danemark ne le
sont pas c'est l'islande et la norvège
et par conséquent ces pays ont une
coopération avec un certain nombre de
sujets techniques sur laquelle ils ont
les projets qu'il mène en commun et puis
enfin la suède
néna n'a pas la volonté d'adhérer dans
l'otan et lorsqu'on lui pose la question
lorsque le secrétaire général le temps
lui pose la question
elle répond non nous voulons bien une
coopération avec le temps mais nous
n'adhérons pas l'otan car nous ne
voulons pas laisser la finlande isolé
toujours est il que dans les débats au
sein du conseil européen
la suède a souvent eu des positions
singulières
elle fait partie des pays frugaux c'est
à dire des pays qui sont opposés
à l'emprunt de 750 milliards d'euros qui
a été décidé l'année dernière parce que
elle trouvait dangereux
cette communautarisation d'une partie de
la dette des états membres cet effort de
solidarité avec une innovation
institutionnelle qui ne lui plaisait pas
et elle est partisan de la rigueur
budgétaire
et puis la semaine dernière au conseil
européen elle fait partie des six ou
sept pays qui se sont opposés à l'idée
d'une reprise un dialogue structuré avec
la russie donc elle à elle elle a pris
le parti de la pologne et des trois pays
baltes pour s'y opposer
certains voient là un roman historique
de 1509 date à laquelle la sueur le
royaume de suède a perdu une bataille
contre pierre le grand mais c'est quand
même bien ancien mairie et que
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales et au yémen à présent de
nouveaux combats font rage dans le nord
du pays des responsables militaires
évoquent le lourd bilan de 111 morts
dans la province de marib théâtre d'une
guerre entre l'armée yéménite et les
rebelles houthi une situation
inextricable pour des millions de civils
déplacés dans le pays dans un conflit
qui perdure malgré les appels au cessez
le feu constant de la part des nations
unies wade belak des positions à tenir
l'armée yéménite en actions et en
discussion
la province de marib riche en pétrole et
disputée depuis quatre mois par les
forces gouvernementales et les rebelles
houthi marib est confronté à une guerre
vicieuse de la part de cette milice qui
tente de contrôler cette ville sous de
nombreux aspects différents
elle a essayé de temps en temps pendant
six ans mais cette dernière bataille
s'est intensifiée depuis un moment au
sud à l'ouest et au nord de la ville de
marib chef lieu de la région portant le
même nom
les combats se sont intensifiés avec des
chiffres incertains selon un dernier
communiqué de l'armée yéménite 16
membres des forces gouvernementales ont
trouvé la mort le week-end dernier
côté outils on en dénombre plus de 34
décédé le 6 juin dernier
les rebelles ont reconnu avoir pris pour
cible une base militaire dans la même
région à proximité de laquelle quatorze
civils ont trouvé la mort
une enquête indépendante a été mandatée
par le mouvement outils et des
indemnités promises en cas de preuve de
sa responsabilité
ce dernier discret sur le nombre de ces
pertes cristallise également les
tensions du côté de sanaa la capitale
tombée dans les rangs outils en 2014
fait l'objet depuis plusieurs années
d'importantes frappe par une coalition
militaire internationale dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite
le clan houthi épaulé par l'iran et qui
a refusé une offre de cessez le feu
proposé par ryad en mars reste ouvert au
dialogue et accepte de recevoir des
émissaires de l'onu
nous espérons qu'avec le soutien du
peuple yéménite sous l'égide des
organisations internationales régionales
et tout le travail que nous avons fait
avec les partis depuis un an nous
pourrons enfin obtenir des résultats la
réunion d'aujourd'hui avec monsieur
martin griffiths s'est concentrée sur
deux points importants
la réouverture de l'aéroport
international de sanaa et la levée du
blocus des ports yéménites ainsi qu'un
retour sans heurts et sans entrave de
l'aide humanitaire à l'accord de
cessez-le-feu conditionnée par les
outils au retour des vols commerciaux
depuis et à destination de sanaa
suspendu depuis 2016 et la levée du
blocus qui asphyxie le pays depuis
bruxelles le chef de la diplomatie
yéménite a demandé à l'union européenne
de prendre plus de responsabilité dans
ce conflit géopolitique aux conséquences
humanitaires désastreuses selon les
nations unies plus des deux tiers des 30
millions d'habitants confronté à
l'épidémie et à la famine dépend de
l'aide internationale et pour en parler
nous sommes avec un gérard vespière
analyse politique chercheur associé à la
fée maubon soir pierre merci d'être avec
nous le contrôle de marib un donc
derniers bastions du pouvoir dans le
nord du pays est tout sauf anodin il
s'agit d'un enjeu éminemment économique
à tout à fait permet aussi de re situer
un petit peu la situation n'est ce pas
parce que on a l'impression par
l'ensemble des communications
médiatiques depuis des années que les
outils gouverne l'intégralité du yémen
et que donc l'arabie saoudite ait said
envahir le yémen pas du tout il voit là
la capitale saana à 120 kilomètres se
trouve cette ville de marib qui est
toujours tenu par le pouvoir
régulièrement élu à du yémen a mené par
le président a dit réfugié en arabie
saoudite
et c'est pour ça que les saoudiens
essaye de faire revenir le président élu
au pouvoir donc marc riboud est un
élément important parce qu'il ya une
petite raffinerie après d'un gisement de
pétrole il ya deux raffineries
donc l'autre et à près de baden et bien
évidemment que malgré les négociations
où les contacts en cours entre arabie
saoudite et l'iran probablement sur le
sujet yéménite et bien les outils essaye
de gagner aussi une carte supplémentaire
économique comme vous ne le dira
politique et d'avoir un avantage dans la
négociation alors la guerre qui fait
rage
des centaines de morts on l'a dit encore
ces derniers jours pourtant il ya ces
appels incessants cessez le feu de l'onu
de la part des des états unis la
situation reste désespérément figé pour
quelles raisons la diplomatie est elle
aussi en échec la diplomatie c'est la
diplomatie des outils premièrement n'est
ce pas il y a déjà eu des négociations
et des accords signés en scandinavie en
suède
ado en 2018 et qui n'ont pas abouti à
des résultats tangibles qui n'ont pas
abouti à l'acceptation par l'air les
outils de la réouverture à de l'aéroport
de sanaa et donc à la libération aussi
des prisonniers des deux côtés donc les
outils ont une volonté affectivement
extrémistes de tenir et le maximum
partie de leurs positions et d'où leur
décision de ne pas céder et de ne pas
d'abou de ne pas aboutir aux accords qui
ont été déjà élaboré par martine
griffith ce négociateur anglais qui agit
pour le nu que nous venons de voir
l'image pourquoi l'aimez rebelles on
tire fait style à la main tendue par
ryad comment comment réamorcer le
dialogue qui sont les parrains n'est ce
pas les paras sont à téhéran a les
outils sont membres d'un point de vue
religieux d'une branche du chiisme donc
et la famille outil a été reçue et a
vécu pendant des dizaines d'années à à
téhéran avant que
donc les iraniens l'europe propose de
revenir en rouille et mène et on a vu le
résultat donc la famille outil a pris la
décision de mener cette révolution dont
kylie a effectivement une volonté aussi
de téhéran de garder ce conflit ouvert
sur le flanc de l'arabie saoudite donc
d'avoir la une monnaie d échange dans
des dialogues et des négociations
internationales
quels territoires occupés t-il
aujourd'hui ces rebelles les rebelles
sont fondamentalement dans la partie
nord ouest du yémen donc c'est une tout
petite enclave phare enclave le mot est
peut être un peu trop limité limitatif
mai à 10 heures une partie va pour cent
du territoire à peu près puisque aden
n'en fait pas partie donc sept
territoires montagnards de montagne avec
cette spécificité religieuse est bien de
tout temps ce n'est pas simplement avec
la famille outils mais déjà il y à milan
il y avait cette partie des de la
péninsule arabique qui étaient agités
par des combats et par des guerres et
c'est un religieux donc père ce qui est
venu avec sa formation donc de cette
branche du chiisme de zaïdites donc de
kia converti entre guillemets qui a
façonné la spécificité religieuse de
cette partie du yémen
les nations unies et on l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises ont qualifié cette
situation au yémen de pire crise
humanitaire en cours dans le monde
on l'a dit ça fait plusieurs années que
ça dure quel avenir selon vous l'avenir
va se jouer entre les grands
responsables entre les parrains savoir
donc l'arabie saoudite et et et l'iran
et il ya des contacts donc qui ont été
établies au mois d'avril à bagdad entre
ces deux pays via leurs émissaires un
respectif qui sont donc des
représentants des services secrets donc
voilà il ya un premier niveau de
dialogue et je pense que là elle c'est
vraiment le point essentiel de
résolution de la situation et minit il
passe par un accord sur le fond entre
l'arabie saoudite et l'iran merci gérard
vespière analyse politique chercheur
associé à la fema d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre analyse en
cisjordanie occupée des affrontements
entre manifestants et forces de sécurité
palestiniennes ont éclaté samedi cela
s'est passé au troisième jour de
protestation déclenché par la mort du
militant palestinien nizar ban a connu
pour ses vidéos critiques contre
l'autorité palestinienne de mahmoud
abbas et précision avec antoine auger
[Musique]
pour les partisans du président mahmoud
abbas tous les coups semblent permis
objectif dissuader les palestiniens de
protester contre la mort du militant des
droits de l'homme
nizar ben and hate brutalement arrêté
jeudi dernier puis placé en détention
parce qu'il critiquait ouvertement sur
internet le président si toute la
lumière n'a pas encore été fait sur sa
mort le médecin légiste révèle que le
décès serait survenu moins d'une heure
après les premiers coups portés par les
autorités palestiniennes indigné le
peuple défilent depuis quatre jours dans
les rues des grandes villes du pays
[Musique]
nizar baraka a été tué pour nous parce
qu'il défend la dignité de la personne
palestinienne la personne palestinienne
se distingue par sa dignité
parmi tous les peuples du monde ils
veulent tuer ce concept chez les
palestiniens et nizar ben and hate
résister parce qu'il refusait de vivre
sans dignité
notre message est que la politique des
autorités pour nous effrayer n'a pas
réussi nous continuons notre lutte notre
travail pacifique juridique et de
défense des droits de l'homme pour
exiger le changement et combattre la
corruption et les corrompus
nizar ben and hate est un symbole pour
tout le peuple palestinien est un
symbole de la liberté d'expression notre
message aux services de sécurité et à
l'autorité est de faire en sorte que
tous les auteurs de ce crime soient
tenus responsables
faute d'obtenir la démission du
président comme ils le réclament les
manifestants ont obtenu celle du
ministre du travail
en effet solidaire avec la gronde des
opposants
le parti du peuple palestinien a décidé
de se retirer des grandes instances
dirigeantes
évoquant un manque de respect des lois
et des libertés publiques
en conséquence nasri abou djeich
ministre du travail qui représentait ce
parti au gouvernement a quitté ses
fonctions au liban ce week-end près
d'une vingtaine de personnes les
manifestants et des soldats ont été
blessés lors de rassemblements nocturnes
à tripoli cela fait suite à une nouvelle
dépréciation record de la monnaie
nationale sur le marché noir
le pays qui s'enfonce dans la crise on
qu'elle prend avec yamina benguigui da
des poubelles brûlées des boutiques
fermées des files interminables aux
stations service c'est le quotidien des
libanais depuis plusieurs mois des
manifestations qui se poursuivent encore
ces jours ci et pour cause une crise
économique majeure qui rend la
population de plus en plus pauvres tous
les gens ont faim personne n'a rien à
manger personne ne peut rien faire
il n'y a pas d'électricité dans les
maisons les enfants ont besoin de lait
personne n'a les moyens d'en acheter
c'est pourquoi nous sommes ici 55% des
libanais vivent aujourd'hui sous le
seuil de pauvreté
la dépréciation de la monnaie nationale
bat des records qualifiant la situation
au liban d'une des pires crises
mondiales jamais connue depuis 1850
selon la banque mondiale le dollar est
maintenant à 16 milles livres et les
files d'attentes humiliante aux stations
services viennent boire hassan nasrallah
les gens meurent de faim et personne ne
s'occupe de regarder autour de vous et
voyez si quelqu'un a un centime qu'il
descende nous qui avons gagné contre
l'ennemi israélien c'est le prix à payer
une dégradation économique qui en vient
à miner un des piliers du liban ces
forces armées dont l'affaiblissement
menacent la sécurité et la stabilité du
pays
son commandement en chef a même lancé un
appel à l'aide à la communauté
internationale elle s'est réunie à
l'initiative de la france lors d'une
conférence organisée le 17 juin dernier
l'union européenne de son côté soutient
qu'un accord avec le fonds monétaire
international est nécessaire mais
conditionnée à une réforme de la
gouvernance politique
une décision soutenue par les états unis
qui appelle le liban a formé un
véritable leadership début plus d'un an
et demi le peuple libanais exige la
transparence la responsabilité et la fin
de la corruption endémique et de la
mauvaise gestion qui sont à l'origine de
ses difficultés
les etats unis la france et la
communauté internationale sont prêts à
aider le liban le liban est engagé dans
un changement significatif mais nous
avons besoin de voir un véritable
leadership avec le chef le pays est sans
gouvernement depuis plus d'un an et demi
malgré deux tentatives échouées de
former une coalition
en cause des querelles entre les
principales forces politiques
certains accusent également
le manque de transparence et la
corruption le liban est soufflé
commémorera le 4 août le premier
anniversaire de l'explosion du port de
beyrouth qui a fait plus de 200 morts et
beyrouth justement une délégation
commerciale russe est en visite sur
place l'occasion de rencontrer des
responsables libanais en vue d'éventuels
projets de reconstruction après
l'explosion du port de la capitale
libanaise l'été dernier qui a fait plus
de 200 morts et des milliers de blessés
le ministre libanais des travaux publics
et des transports se dit optimiste j'ai
eu l'honneur aujourd'hui d'accueillir
l'ambassadeur de russie à la tête d'une
délégation d'experts techniques russe
sur plusieurs sujets liés à l'étude des
ports ils ont exprimé leur volonté de
coopérer avec le liban est d'apporter
une aide technique au port de tripoli et
à celui de beyrouth
la délégation passera trois jours au
port de tripoli et trois jours à celui
de beyrouth
elle étudiera la possibilité de
construire de nouveaux silos à grains
tripoli et à beyrouth viendront sur la
propagation du variant delta qui
accélère notamment au portugal
le pays met en place de nouvelles
restrictions et puis elles ont des voix
s'élèvent pour que la demi finale et la
finale de l'euro de foot ne se déroule
pas web blé en cause tous bords le
variant indien
m
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise ces firmes
mais comment peuvent-ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents à ce point
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins il
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental on est tous
conscients que le football ligny tout ce
qui le niveau social surtout au niveau
culture et quel regard portez-vous sur
toutes ces années à monaco à la cheville
tous en équipe de france le football le
football c'est ma vie et le football m'a
beaucoup donné en temps dans tous les
contextes et quand on a la chance de
revenir en étant ambassadeur voir les
gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a
faits n'ont surtout au niveau au niveau
football et ça c'est c'est touchant
[Musique]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement ad décidant par
votre mouvement c'est des accusations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé ni les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui son chéri est-ce que
désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a guère a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
détermination pour laisser les sahraouis
le choix de choisir le futur de choisir
entre l'indépendance et l'intégration
marque à savoir que ce n'est pas une
partie du territoire marocain
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
et
deux termes banlieue voir le tome 6 tc
forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que les
médias ont un regard on va dire assez
particulier des banlieues et qui dérange
aujourd'hui et en donne cette impression
que la banlieue ça se résoudrait cas des
jeunes violents contre une police qui
serait son travail c'est plus compliqué
que ça on est français on est fiers de
vivre dans ces quartiers même s'il ya
des difficultés est la moindre des
choses c'est d'inscrire aussi notre
empreinte
quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement il n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses
mais concrètement politiquement ils ne
le font pas
[Musique]
je n'ai
21h soyez les bienvenus pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 28 juin le variant delta identifié
pour la première fois en 1 joue les
trouble fête en ce début d'été le
calendrier des levée des restrictions se
voit chamboulé en raison de 50 et josy t
portugal royaume-uni ou encore russie
doivent à nouveau serré la vis de quoi
inquiéter alors que londres et
saint-pétersbourg sont les villes hôtes
de l'euro de foot une violation
flagrante de la souveraineté réaction de
l'irak après que les etats-unis ont
annoncé cette nuit avoir procédé à des
frappes aériennes à la frontière irako
syrienne contre les milices soutenues
par l'iran selon le pentagone ces
bombardements visaient des centres
opérationnels et des dépôts d'armes
stupeur au canada après nouvelle
découverte macabre celle de centaines de
tombes anonymes aux abords d'un
pensionnats pour autochtones de l'ouest
du pays
le premier ministre justin trudeau était
revenue longuement la semaine dernière
sur les terribles erreurs du canada qui
a mené pendant plusieurs siècles une
politique controversée d'assimilation
forcée des premières nations
venez
[Musique]
si la situation épidémique était à
l'amélioration depuis plusieurs semaines
le variant delta vient ainsi chamboulé
le calendrier des levée de restrictions
de nombreux pays
certains sont contraints de durcir leurs
mesures alors que la période estivale se
profile entre confinement et quarantaine
tour d'horizon avec emma y assembler un
était loin des restrictions semble se
profiler
mais un rebond épidémique plane aux
quatre coins du monde depuis plusieurs
semaines le variant delta anciennement
indien devient majoritaire dans de
nombreux pays au portugal ils
représentent désormais plus de 51% des
contaminations et 70% à lisbonne des
chiffres inquiétants qui ont poussé le
pays à durcir à nouveau les restrictions
dans les régions les plus touchées dans
la capitale entre autres la capacité
d'accueil des restaurants a été réduite
et les commerces non alimentaires
doivent fermer à 15h30 un confinement a
également été mise en place à lisbonne
le week-end une mesure qui s'avère
nécessaire pour certains résidents même
si ces mesures sont durs il faut
comprendre que le gouvernement doit
prendre des mesures pour nous protéger
faisant partie du monde nous nous devons
d'être solidaire même son de cloche en
australie depuis ce week-end sydney se
voir confiné pour 15 jours
d'autres villes du pays ont également
durci leurs mesures sanitaires en france
également la crainte se fait ressentir
détecté dans les landes est présent dans
le bas rhin ou encore l'isère le variant
reste encore minoritaire sur le
territoire mais pourrait représenter 90%
des contaminations fin août
selon le centre européen de prévention
et de contrôle des maladies
une situation qui pourrait retarder la
levée de certaines restrictions selon
gabriel attal on a une situation qui
s'est améliorée au niveau national mais
il ya une préoccupation avec ce variant
delta énormément plus contagieux que le
variant historique
si on observe une reprise de l'épidémie
importante dans un département ça peut
nous amener à retarder un certain nombre
d'allègement de jo
ceux qui n'ont pas encore eu lieu anguel
a.merkel très inquiète de la situation
épidémique appelle à la plus grande
prudence
le portugal et la russie ont été placés
sur la liste des pays acp variant par
l'allemagne
les personnes admises devront respecter
une quarantaine de deux semaines même en
possession d'un test pcr négatif
une décision regrettée par le
gouvernement portugais
la chancelière qui a appelé à une
coordination étroite entre les membres
de l'union européenne au sujet de
l'ouverture à des pays tiers tels que le
royaume-uni et la russie pays qui
connaissent une lourde dégradation de la
situation sanitaire à cause de
l'émergence du variant delta raison sur
la situation au portugal ou de variant
d'un taille désormais prédominant et
pourrait bien gâcher déconfinement pour
en parler
nous sommes en direct avec céline le
riche médecin généraliste française
exerçant à lisbonne bonsoir
céline leriche merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce variant un delta
qui nous causent bien d'inquiétude qui
représente maintenant plus de 51 % des
nouveaux cas au portugal plus de 70% de
la région de lisbonne
sa propagation est inéluctable comment
vous vous l'expliquer en tant que
médecin oui bonsoir il s'avère que le
portugal se retrouve
avec un gros dilemme c'est que on se
retrouve avec 1604 contamination par
jour depuis presque une semaine dont
plus de 1200 à lisbonne dont 70% des
contaminations alors que les lisbonne et
son aire métropolitaine ne représentent
que 27 % de la population totale du
portugal c'est une ville on avait
commencé le plan de déconfinement à
partir de mi mars avec la réouverture
des écoles qui ont été fermées pendant
deux mois et on procéder par étape en
ouvrant les terrasses les restaurants
etc
est on arrivé à un stade où la quatrième
phase de déconfinement du coup n'a pas
pu être envisageable à lisbonne
puisqu'on est passé au dessus du taux
d'incidence qui est de plus de 240
personnes pour cent mille habitants
alors vous vous travaillez oui vous
travaillez dans une clinique privée à
lisbonne expliquez nous comment ça se
passe les symptômes haskell son
différend avec ce variant delpastre
stade en inquiète plus on voit en tout
cas moins d'hospitalisations moins
d'hospitalisations en réanimation et
donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant est-ce
que c'est dû aux variants delta qui
serait plus contagieux certes mais
peut-être pas forcément avec une
mortalité plus forte
ou est-ce que tout simplement les gens
fragiles à risque d'hospitalisation ou
d'être admis en réanimation sont
vaccinés il faut pas oublier que le
portugal réussi à vacciner 42 % de sa
population avec une dose et 27% de la
population totale du portugal a reçu les
deux doses
donc je ne peux pas dire si le variant
delta permet et moins à une mortalité
moindre ou si c'est tout simplement
parce que la population a été vaccinée
vous voyez beaucoup de patients qui ont
été vaccinés
et qui ont contracté ce delta beaucoup
non mais quelques-uns et ils sont dans
quel état en général ce sont des
symptômes sans gravité quand ils ont été
vaccinées alors ce que j'ai vu comme je
suis dans une clinique qui n'a pas de
réanimation et soins continus non c'est
forcément des gens qui ne sont non pas
des symptômes graves parce que ceux-là
sont directement dirigés à l'hôpital
mais clairement le nom de deux mois
journalier et le nombre
d'hospitalisations en réanimation est
très faible
les nouvelles restrictions on rappelle
les horaires et la capacité donc
d'accueil des des restaurants et des
commerces ont de nouveau été réduite est
ce que c'est c'est suffisant pour vous
pardon excusez moi j'ai pas entendu les
nouvelles restrictions qui ont été mises
en place au portugal est ce qu'elles
sont suffisantes pour vous elles sont
quand même pas mal c'est à dire que les
restaurants et commerces doivent fermer
à 15h30 les samedis et dimanches et les
samedis et dimanches donc week-end à
partir du vendredi 15 heures jusqu'au
lundi matin 6 heures on n'a pas le droit
de circuler en dehors de l'airé
métropolitaine de lisbonne il ya en ce
moment le l'euro de foot qui se joue on
en a parlé il ya quelques instants avec
cette nouvelle notamment d'ailleurs 300
supporters qui sont revenus de moscou
testé positif au col vide
est-ce que clairement cette compétition
et le fait qu'on fasse des matchs avec
voilà
des milliers de personnes dans des
stades c'est de nature à relancer
l'épidémie oui et non parce que au
niveau par exemple n'y a pas de fan zone
il n'ya pas les bars ferment à 22h30 la
semaine 15h30 le week-end donc autant
dire qu'on peut pas voir il n'y a pas de
match diffusé à l'extérieur
après c'est sûr que les tests
antigénique au pcr de 72 48 heures
laisse quand même passé des gens qui
sont potentiellement positif il n'y a
pas que l'euro il ya eu la finale de la
champion's league entre deux clubs
anglais qui a eu lieu le 29 mai à porto
conclusion l'europe pas assez vacciner
selon vous je dirais que la vaccination
permet je pense malgré tout vu le nombre
de contaminations quotidien d'avoir
moins d'hospitalisations et -2
d'admission en réanimation mais
probablement qu'elle suffira pas à
enrayer les contaminations on voit bien
dans divers pays qui ont été vaccinés ou
presque la moitié la population se
retrouve avec des pcr positive et que
c'est une solution mais c'est peut-être
pas le miracle
merci céline le riche médecin
généraliste français exerçant lisbonne
d'avoir été avec nous avoir exposé la
situation au portugal avec désormais
donc la domination de ce barillon delta
une situation préoccupante également en
russie face à l'importante circulation
du variant saint pétersbourg et moscou
vient d'enregistrer leur plus fort taux
de décès depuis le début de la pandémie
est détaillé avec notre correspondante
verhaeghe à eau froide sans aucun doute
toutes les situations de déficit du
vaccin seront compensées a déclaré le
porte parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
il a également souligné qu'il était
impossible de stocker le remède dans de
grandes quantités sur tout le territoire
du pays et qu'il faudrait accélérer
livraison du vaccin dans les régions
russes je vous propose d'écouter
dieu merci il y à une forte augmentation
du nombre de personnes souhaitant se
faire vacciner
comme nous le savons il faut également
prendre en compte les conditions
nécessaires pour le stockage du vaccin
il est tout simplement impossible de le
stocker dans de grandes quantités sur
tout le territoire
oui il faudra donc accéléré toute la
chaîne logistique
l'ensemble de la chaîne compte tenu du
fait que les citoyens ont commencé à
faire preuve d'une plus grande
conscience d'une meilleure compréhension
du danger qui nous menace tous il ne
fait donc aucun doute que dans les
prochains jours toutes ces situations de
déficit seront compensés actuellement il
n'y a pas de vaccination obligatoire
pour les citoyens russes les régions
impose des conditions de vaccination
obligatoire pour travailler dans
certains domaines mais ce n'est pas
nécessairement une vaccination pour tous
les citoyens quand ministre russe de la
santé michael morell où il a affirmé que
23 millions de russes avaient déjà reçu
au moins une injection du vaccin et que
la situation avec la maladie était un
peu plus simple maintenant que l'année
dernière écoutez aujourd'hui la
situation autour du coronavirus est un
peu plus simple à quai les gars il
existe déjà des vaccins dans le monde
mais il n'y a toujours pas de
médicaments qui affecte radicalement
l'évolution du corona virus il existe
des médicaments qui sont efficaces au
stade initial et jusqu'au degré de
gravité modérée
il en existe plusieurs autres or pour
l'instant on ne peut pas dire que c'est
une infection contrôlé à 100% de
nouvelles restrictions entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui à moscou et dans sa banlieue
les chefs d'entreprises seront obligés
de rétablir le télétravail pour 30 % des
employés non vaccinés l'accès aux
restaurants et cafés se fera désormais
par le biais du code qr qui sera
disponible uniquement à ceux qui ont un
test pcr négative un certificat de
vaccination complète ou encore un
justificatif des anticorps valable six
mois après la maladie
le nombre des contaminations aux
tendances partout en russie plus de 21
mille nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont
été détectés aujourd'hui dans le pays
donc plus de 7000 à moscou et alors que
l'on observe une résurgence de 4go vide
en russie l'organisation du quart de
finale de l'euro à saint-pétersbourg
inquiète
un porte parole de l'uefa a déclaré
aujourd'hui que la situation sanitaire
russe ne changeait absolument rien pour
les équipes et qu'il n'était pas prévu
de changer le lieu du match
la même question se pose en angleterre
avec les demi finales et finales prévues
à londres
les autorités elles se veulent toujours
rassurante mais aujourd'hui l'un des
vice-présidents de la commission
européenne émet des doutes écouter un
titre personnel je mets le partager guru
à titre personnel j'aimerais partager
avec vous mes doutes sur la possibilité
d'organiser la finale et la demi finale
à wembley dans un stade comble au moment
où le royaume uni limite les
déplacements de ses citoyens vers
l'union européenne où le royaume mis
eux-mêmes limite les déplacements de
leurs un citoyen vers l'union européenne
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec un martin mc cauley
analyse politique c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir martin mec colis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient de le constater on a le sentiment
que ceux des confinement autour de
l'euro ça devient véritablement une
question quasi politique les messieurs
hancock qui a démissionné en tant que me
sers de la santé était une personne très
prudente été très prudent dans son
approche du déconfinement mais le
nouveau secrétaire de la synthèse
ministre de la santé s'agit que j'habite
est bien plus rapide que pensent
beaucoup plus à l'économie
et il affirme donc que le confinement et
les restrictions prendront fin le 19
juillet c'est ce que la plupart des gens
veulent entendre les bien sûr il faut
attendre
aujourd'hui nous avons eu 25 mille
nouveaux cas au royaume 9 et ce n'est
pas la fin de l'épidémie au royaume uni
vous vous faites référence à ce ministre
de la santé qui a dû démissionner ce
week-end après cette vidéo
compromettante 1 il embrassait une femme
qui n'était pas la sienne voilà hasard
ou coïncidence
cette vidéo qui a été publié ça tombait
bien qu'ils soient sont poussés vers la
sortie en ce moment justement pour faire
primer l'économie alors de l'euro abel
belgique l'égard de pékin mais c'est
très mauvais pour le gouvernement car le
premier ministre avait dit l' affaire
est close matin coque restera ministre
de la santé
et puis bien sûr matin coq a lui même
décidé de démissionner et cela a mis le
gouvernement difficultés les points clés
de cette démission
ce sont les images enregistrées par une
caméra placée étant son propre bureau
qui a enregistré une embrassade entre
lui et son assistant
donc c'est devenu un sujet politique car
cela pourrait également devenir un
problème de sécurité
ces caméras à circuit fermé aurait pu
capter des images de documents sur son
bureau et ces documents auraient pu
contenir des informations très
importantes notamment en matière de
sécurité
nous ne savons donc pas pour le moment
si l'on va étudier le sujet si les
services de sécurité vont me prendre la
sphère en main pour le moment ils
essayent de minimiser la situation
il espère que les images captées par ces
caméras
nous mettrons pas le gouvernement en
difficulté la caméra a été supprimée par
de nouveaux ministres de la santé et
c'est vraiment une situation très
embarrassante pour le gouvernement et au
pire moment bien sûr car l'épidémie
reprend au royaume uni et nous avons
besoin de quelqu'un d'expérimenté au
pouvoir le nouveau ministre de la santé
va trouver son emploi difficile mais
comme je les dis ils se préoccupent plus
d'économies que de confinement donc il
maintient cette date du 19 juillet pour
la fin du confinement et au milieu donc
leur oms qui s'inquiètent de
l'assouplissement autour de certains
matches de l'euro on rappelle quand même
qu'on a pris officiellement aujourd'hui
près de 300 supporters été testé positif
de retour en finlande après avoir
assisté à l'euro le ffa qui met un petit
peu la pression quand même que peut être
l'attitude de londres des autorités
britanniques c'est très cornélien
l'économie ou ou la santé
ça se pose clairement c'est une question
très intéressante car f1 a dit que la
finale pourrait être transférée à
budapest en hongrie et dans ce stade de
puskas à budapest
on peut accueillir autant de fans que
c'est possible mais je n'oublie ce n'est
pas le cas et de nombreuses personnes
pour se rendre à londres pour la finale
et le fêter on n'a pas demandé à ses
représentants de l'uefa de se soumettre
à une quarantaine le gouvernement
britannique doit à dessiner décider si
la
nahla à wembley de prendre place ce qui
effectivement est un enjeu économique
majeur
si du point de vue sanitaire ils doivent
considérer que le risque est trop élevé
et que cette finale pourrait introduire
des personnes contaminées au royaume uni
et qu'il faudrait donc transférer cette
finale à budapest mais la finale prendra
place je crois le 31 juillet nous avons
encore beaucoup de temps il faut donc
attendre et voir
car j'avais le nouveau ministre de la
santé a déclaré que toutes les
restrictions seraient levés le 19
juillet c'est dans c'est donc toujours
avant la finale il faut voir ce qui va
arriver
les supporteurs britanniques adoré avoir
une finale à londres
ils ont de grands espoirs et espère
également que l'équipe d'angleterre sera
en finale mais cela serait peut-être
trop dangereux et donc il faut attendre
car comme je voulais dit il y a eu
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
nouveaux karts de coronavirus
aujourd'hui à londres royaume uni
pour le gouvernement c'est un choix
véritablement cornélien beaucoup de
personnes dirais que c'est trop
dangereux que l'argent n'est pas
important par rapport à la santé de la
population
point de vue des affaires du point de
vue des médias cependant il faudrait que
la finale prennent place à londres car
cela génère est énorme somme d'argent et
cela rendrait londres très populaire
merci beaucoup partie nommée colis
analyses politiques d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir
pays voisins du liban israël où le
nouveau premier ministre 9 talibés net
appelle les plus jeunes à aller se faire
vacciner en urgence contre le
coronavirus une urgence qui s'explique
par là encore une hausse de 4
contamination influencé par la
propagation du variant delta au moins
40% des personnes positif aux variants
ont reçu les deux doses de vaccin autre
raison de cette précipitation du premier
ministre un stock de sérum qui arrive à
sa date de péremption naftali bennet
récemment et lui donne 11 jours à la
jeune population pour passer le cap de
la vaccination écouter la nouvelle
souche delta du corona fait rage dans le
monde entier
elle est très contagieuse et elle ni aux
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
c'est à dire vous les jeunes il y
actuellement suffisamment de vaccins
pour tout le monde mais il ya un hic
leur validité va bientôt expirer et nous
n'aurons alors plus assez de vaccins
pour tout le monde
cela signifie qu'il ya une courte
fenêtre de 11 jours et que nous sommes
dans une course contre la montre
la dernière date à laquelle il sera
possible de se faire vacciner avec le
premier vaccin et le 9 juillet et trois
semaines plus tard
vous recevrez le deuxième vaccin ensuite
les vaccins que nous avons en stock
expireront par conséquent j'appelle les
parents et j'appelle tous les
adolescents filles et garçons qui
peuvent se faire vacciner
sortez maintenant vous faire vacciner
avant que vous ne puissiez plus et en
tunisie à présent le gouvernement parle
d'une situation critique le pays à new
york ont fini vendredi dernier plus de
28 communes dans plusieurs régions et ce
jusqu'au 11 juillet en raison de la
situation sanitaire au plus de
précisions nous retrouverons tout une
belle scène chebbi notre correspondant à
tunis
bonsoir baisse m
l'écart ne font qu'augmenter à en
tunisie également avec toujours cette
crainte que le variant delta ne
s'installe largement le gouvernement a
déjà d'ailleurs pris certaines
dispositions
bassem chebi en direct de tunis est ce
que vous nous entendez ça ne semble pas
être le cas
bassem aux noms ya un petit souci de
leçon on va retrouver peut-être bcm un
petit peu plus tard en tout cas on va
marquer une courte pause dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous
évoquerons des frappes militaires
américaines en irak contre des centres
opérationnels appartenant à des
ministres aux iraniennes et puis nous
parlerons de la découverte du reste de
plusieurs centaines d'enfants
d'autochtones au canada
[Musique]
on
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers ont été compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rex it
le vrai sujet c'est celui de faire
dialoguer les douaniers français les
poignées britannique est ce qui
m'inquiète dans le bric side c'est par
le président c'est la bureaucratie du
brics comment ça va se passer par
exemple pour l'été qui arrive la côte
d'azur verra peu ou pas d'anglais je
suspecte effectivement le gouvernement
britannique d'essayer de convaincre les
britanniques de rester en grande
bretagne pour faciliter la relance de
l'économie britannique par rapport à la
crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soir vient des
lignes ans aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrêmement sujet de maths et la science
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté jour merci
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses les chiffres qui sont
avancés qui sont montrés aux salariés et
à leurs représentants sont des chiffres
en décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents ce point
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique nos une
vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement reste que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les production de
vaccins où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup danger sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
importants ainsi que le nigeria affirme
qu'il élabore son propre vaccin contre
le coc u19 pour en finir avec justement
la dépendance vis-à-vis des laboratoires
à l'étranger que ce soit le sénégal le
nigeria l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener la générale de la santé
publique au toc des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et
[Musique]
21h33 les bienvenus en direct sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez les
etats-unis ont frappé la nuit dernière
des installations situées à la frontière
entre l'irak et la syrie
un raid aérien mené par le pentagone qui
le justifie par des attaques répétées
ces dernières semaines contre les
troupes américaines déployées en irak
pour plus de précisions retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter thomas bonnin en
direct de washington bonsoir thomas que
sait-on précisément de cette opération
militaire américaine
eh bien ce sont des frappes qui ont été
menées sur ordre du président américain
joe biden contre ce qui est présenté par
le pentagone comme des installations
utilisées par les milices soutenues par
l'iran le pentagone présente ce raid
aérien comme des frappes défensives
contre 3,6 définis comme des centres
opérationnels et des dépôts d'armes des
lieux où les américains accusent ces
milices pro et rend donc de préparer des
attaques contre la coalition a déployé
en irak notamment à l'aide de drones
pour les autorités américaines cette
opération militaire avait pour but
d'envoyer un signal fort et de
réaffirmer la volonté du président
bailon de protéger les troupes
américaines déployées sur place écoutez
le secrétaire d'état anthony blinken a
action in search of hand à cette action
de défense a été nécessaire pour
prévenir de futures attaques
je pense que c'est un message important
à acro match et j'espère sincèrement que
ce message a été reçu
je pense que nous l'avons démontré avec
des actions menées cette nuit et les
actions menées avant que le président
soit pleinement prête à agir agir de
façon appropriée et délibérément pour
protéger les intérêts américains
les intérêts du peuple et notre
personnel est thomas des attaques
vivement condamnée par les autorités
locales
oui le premier ministre irakien a fait
part de sa colère après cette opération
américaine il condamne je cite une
violation flagrante et inacceptable de
la souveraineté irakienne ainsi que de
la sécurité nationale du pays
écoutez le premier ministre d'irak nous
réitérons notre refus de voir l'irak
comme un terrain pour régler les comptes
et sommes attachés à notre droit
d'empêcher que le pays ne soit utilisé
comme un chant d'agression et de
représailles
même condamnation du côté des autorités
iraniennes qui soulignent le fait que
washington avec cette frappe perturbe la
sécurité et créer le chaos dans la
région des agissements qui pourrait se
retourner contre les etats-unis selon
les propos du porte parole de la
diplomatie iranienne depuis le début de
l'année une quarantaine d' attaques ont
visé des soldats américains en irak des
attaques dont washington estime qu'elles
sont l'oeuvre de factions pro iranienne
c'est donc en représailles que ce raid
aérien a été mené le deuxième depuis
l'arrivée au bout coupure de deux
liaisons avec thomas abonnés qui
arrivait de tout ça soir sa conclusion
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et pour approfondir ce sujet
nous sommes
en direct avec abel adèle pardon bacau
directeur du centre français de
recherche sur l'irak bonsoir monsieur
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france les attaques contre les intérêts
américains semblent augmenter ces
derniers mois pour quelles raisons la
raison est très simple vous savez d'où
2003 à 2018 fin 2018
l'irak qui nous disposait pas et qui ne
dispose toujours pas des infrastructures
pour fonctionner autant que est un
souverain a
ils étaient autant que keita
opérationnel parce qu'il y avait un
accord entre washington et téhéran pour
faire fonctionner cet état irradiant
autrement dit il y avait une concorde il
avait un parfum partenariat une
cogestion américano iranienne pour gérer
l'eau dossier irakien l'état irakien
l'homme possible et aération
on défend 2018 plus précisément le 26
décembre 2018 donald trump arrive à en
irak
il y a atterri sur la base est à la base
militaire al assad en irak et il fait
une déclaration en disant que la
présence américaine en irak vise à
surveiller les activités de la
république islamique de l'iran au moyen
orient
le lendemain c'était le cas où c'était
le choc c'était la panique pourquoi
parce que tout simplement par cette
déclaration donald trump a mis fin à
cette cogestion américano iranienne de
de ces irakiens et depuis fin 2010 8
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
lo péi fin l'irak et vit dans le cas où
dans votre désordre c'est la guerre de
tous contre tous vous n'avez pas un
gouvernement stable vous avez un
mouvement de contestation très très fort
vous avez des des confrontations entre
les iraniens
les pro iranien et les américains il y à
des attaques réciproques les pro iranien
vise l'ambassade les aéroports les bases
militaires américains dans le pays les
forces armées américaines vie
les différentes milices irakiennes des
deux côtés de l'art de la frontiète à
fourrure frontère c'est à dire en irak
et en syrie
et voilà le contexte global dans lequel
on se trouve alors les ministres
responsables de ces attaques seraient
liées à l'appareil sécuritaire irakien
mais financée par lire o 1 comment est
ce possible ministre pro iranienne
prennent de l'ampleur en irak
écoutez on n'ira que j'ai pas très très
bien entendu votre question alors si la
question c'est sur les milices pro
iranienne en irak c'est que vous
aujourd'hui on n'ira que vous avez trois
catégories du ministre vous avez des
milices nationalistes représentées
incarné par moqtada sadr vous avez les
milices de la marche à incarner pareil
pour l'assistanat et vous avez des
milices pro iranienne a représenté
surtout par kataëb hezbollah les les
attaques contre les intérêts américains
en irak sont souvent à 99.99 pour sont
conduits par cette faction c'est ce
groupe qui s'appelle kh2 les kataëb
hezbollah
alors donc c'est pourquoi les états unis
d'amérique vise nous pas les milices
nationaliste nous par les milices de la
marche arrière mais plutôt des milices
pro iranien l'état irakien dénoncé en
tout cas une violation grave de la
souveraineté irakienne est ce que vous
comprenez cette réaction est ce que
c'est le cas nous allons absolument pas
à vous que vous savez en irak c'est
qu'on déclare officiellement est ce
qu'on fait dans l'écho liste ce sont
deux choses complètement radicalement
différente
ces attaques
contre les milices pro iranienne ne
peuvent être produisent sans la
coordination dans les coulisses avec les
autorités irakiennes
mustapha kazmi et bien évidemment dans
l'obligation sous voies dans le rôle de
condamner aux tankers premier ministre
ces attaques mais en réalité on sait
très bien qu'il y a un partenariat très
fort entre le gouvernement régional du
kurdistan le gouvernement de 15 me et
les forces américaines sur le sol
irakien
c'est grâce à cette coordination que les
états unis d'amérique et peuvent viser
ces milices pro iranienne donc non je ne
suis pas étonné lorsque jean poncet
déclaration qui condamne ces attaques
mais ce qui se passe ce qui m'intéresse
moi c'est ce qui se passe dans les
coulisses et nous passer une telle
déclaration
et qu'est ce qui se passe alors dans les
coulisses jusqu'où ça peut aller
ces tensions c'est très simple a
cependant que nous sommes en train de
dialoguer ensemble vous et moi il y à
des négociations a à la fois à bagdad et
à erbil entre les américains et les
iraniens il ya il ya eu un processus de
négociations donald trump à fin 2010 8
rompt avec cette cogestion avec cette
concorde avec l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche au pouvoir aux états
unis d'amérique
le président américain a la volonté à la
volonté de remettre en place cette
cogestion parce qu'il sait très bien
lui-même il s'est rendu en irak 24 x 24
x 1
pendant ces déchirants montas il connaît
parfaitement le terrain irakien il
connaît chaque communauté chaque acteur
il connaît les élites irak a ni le kun
et les institutions de cet état qui
n'est plus opérationnel et il sait très
bien pour stabiliser le minimum pour
sécuriser l'eau minimum ira pour
développer le minimum possible ce pays
là il faut absolument faire en accord
avec la république islamique d'iran sans
lequel le pays sera vraiment dans le
chaos absolu
voir la guerre de tout le monde compte
actuellement c'est à dire la guerre
civile et pour cela je byden souhaite
remettre en place cogestion seulement et
les américains et les iraniens à erbil
et et bagdad à ce jusqu'à aujourd'hui
n'arrive pas à trouver une formule est
parce qu ils sont tendres dans le
processus engagé dans ce processus de
négociation ils l'envoient
réciproquement des messages par des
roquettes par des attaques par des
prises en otage par des missiles et donc
toutes ces opérations là la seule leçon
à retenir c'est que il monte en
puissance pour peser sur les
négociations en cours à hermine et avec
dac
merci adel bat kahone directeur du
centre français de recherche irak
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france faire changer les mentalités face
au racisme systémique à c'est l'appel
lancé ce matin par le haut commissaire
des droits de l'homme de l'onu michele
bachelet qui exhorte les états je cite à
démanteler ce fléau et ce quelques jours
après la condamnation à 22 ans et demi
de prison aux etats-unis de derek
chauvin le policier à l'origine de la
mort de l'afro américain george clooney
il ya un an à minneapolis
le statu quo est intenable le racisme
systémique nécessite une réponse
systémique
nous avons besoin d'une approche
transformatrices qui s'attaque au
domaine interconnectés qui alimente le
racisme et conduisent à des tragédies
répétées et totalement évitables comme
la mort de georges floyd j'appelle tous
les états a cessé de nier et a commencé
à démanteler le racisme à mettre fin à
l'impunité et à instaurer la confiance à
écouter les voix des personnes
d'ascendance africaine a affronté les
héritages du passé et à offrir des
réparations les états doivent faire
preuve d'une volonté politique plus
forte pour accélérer l'action en faveur
de la justice de la réparation et de
l'égalité raciale en prenant des
engagements spécifiques et assortis de
délais pour obtenir des résultats
au canada des incendies d'églises se
multiplient dans l'ouest du pays deux
nouveaux bâtiments étaient détruits par
les flammes ce samedi dans une réserve
d'amérindiens de la colombie britannique
et si à ce stade de l'enquêté la police
ne s'avance pas sur les raisons de ces
sinistres difficile de ne pas y voir un
lien avec une découverte récente de
sépulture amérindienne près d'écoles
catholiques des événements qui ravive le
passé tragique du pays françois tessier
beach elles se sont embrasés à moins
d'une heure d'intervalle l'église
sainte-anne et l'église show paca situé
sur des terres de collectivités
autochtones dans le sud de la colombie
britannique ont été ravagés par les
flammes ce samedi matin deux sinistres
qui viennent s'ajouter à deux incendies
de lieux de culte le 21 juin dernier
dans une autre réserve de la province
les autorités considèrent que ces
incendies sont suspects et cherche à
vérifier s'ils ont un lien avec les
incendies d'églises survenu le 21 juin
painting tonnes et oliver si les
enquêtes sont encore en cours
ces nouveaux incendies interviennent
quelques jours après la découverte de
sept cent cinquante et une sépulture
amérindienne sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat catholique
une découverte qui vient s'ajouter à
celle du mois dernier avec
l'identification de restes de 215
enfants près d'un autre établissement du
même type et qui ravive un pan tragique
de l'histoire canadienne
il est possible qu'il s'agisse d'un
tournant mais cela dépend de la façon
dont le gouvernement veut réagir et de
ce qu'il va dire aux communautés des
premières nations
nous n'en sommes qu'au tout début ce
n'est que la deuxième découverte public
du début du 19e siècle jusque dans les
années 1990 quelques 150 mille enfants
amérindiens métis ou inuit ont été
enrôlés de force dans 139 pensionnat à
travers le pays dans le but d'être
assimilée à la culture dominante coupés
de leurs familles de leur langue et de
leur culture
nombre d'entre eux y ont subi mauvais
traitements et abus sexuels une
commission d' enquête datant de 2015
avait même conclu un véritable génocide
culturel évoquant la mort de plus de
4000 personnes dans ces établissements
bien choisi c'était un crime contre
l'humanité une attaque contre le peuple
des premières nations
nous sommes un peuple fier le seul crime
que nous ayons commis en tant qu'enfants
et date rené autochtone et il ya
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de guérison
à faire il y a beaucoup de sites où nous
allons nous allons faire ce travail
similaires et nous en trouverons
d'autres vendredi justin trudeau s'est
excusé au nom du gouvernement du canada
se disant horrifié et honteux de la
façon dont le pays a agi
le premier ministre a par ailleurs
annoncé un accord financier de plus de 3
millions d'euros avec des communautés
autochtones dans le but d'entreprendre
et de continuer les recherches sur les
sites de pensionnat de son côté l'église
catholique canadienne multiplie les
gestes de bonne volonté
deux communautés qui gérait 48
pensionnat ont déclaré qu'elles allaient
permettre l'accès aux documents
historiques en leur possession afin
d'établir la vérité de ce qui s'est
passé dans ces écoles et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jérôme blanchet gravel
essayiste correspondante de spoutnik au
canada bonsoir jérôme blanchet grave et
merci d'être avec nous un millier de
tombes anonymes donc découverte au
canada au cours du mois dernier
et ce n'est que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg oui sans doute comme le
reportage l'a dit bien c'est le début ce
processus donc le gouvernement fédéral
s'est engagé à poursuivre les recherche
donc c'est sûr que compte tenu du nombre
de jeunes d'enfants autochtones qui ont
été placés par le gouvernement fédéral
au 19ème au xxème siècle donc 150000
quand même quand on peut s'attendre à
nous découvrir d'autres fausses
d'enfants les sépultures dont
l'identifier et c'est donc évidemment
c'est en cache pas que c'est une
tragédie c'est un deuil national
il ya un consensus au canada autour de
la volonté de fin la réconciliation
c'est le grand thème qui avait annoncé
justin trudeau
donc autant à gauche qu'à droite je vous
dirais que deux mondes est assez
d'accord pour faire ce travail aux
seules mains de réparation à vers les
peuples autochtones alors les peuples
autochtones qui ne représente que 3% de
la population canadienne ça veut dire
qu'en gros ils ont vécu un véritable
génocide
est ce que le racisme est toujours
présent aujourd'hui une sorte de
effectivement de racisme historique
moi j'hésite à utiliser le terme
systémique parce que bon le racisme
systémique on le trouve un peu partout
et nulle part c'est un thème c'est un
peu un fantôme qui plane sur au dessus
de nos sociétés dont qu'il donne à la
gauche antiraciste abuse beaucoup de ce
concept là mais moi je parlerais
personnellement plus d'une sorte de
racisme est historique c'est à dire que
il est évident que il y encore des
séquelles la colonisation il ya un
traumatisme chez les communautés
amérindiennes qui est encore présent
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut parler de génocide
dont une célèbre commission d'enquêté
conclut un génocide
il faut quand même préciser que les
enfants n'étaient pas assassiné dans les
pensionnats lé don qu'il mourrait en
grande partie de maladies et de mauvais
traitements remarquez toute la lumière
n'est pas faite sur les d'histoire mais
parler de génocide c'est quand même
peut-être un peu fort un regard
il faut replacer aussi dans le contexte
historique les enfants à cape town n'ont
pas été les seules personnes à vildé
abus d'accord des églises chrétiennes au
canada et des pleins aussi bisexuelle
donc nous allons dire que y'a un gros
travail à faire et c'est un sujet très
sensible et comment réagissent les
canadiens parce que c'est vrai que
depuis la france on vous écoute on
trouve ça à peine croyable des canadiens
sont sont choqués de cela il ya une
vraie demande de réparations versés ces
populations
tu te fais jeudi il y avait un consensus
une prise de conscience il ya un réveil
donc ma droite le où on avait peut-être
été un peu plus insensible face au sort
des communautés autochtones
on sent qu'il ya vraiment une volonté
d'un effort collectif qui va être fait
donc c'est positif
moi je suis je suis pour ça je suis dit
il faudrait quand même rappeler que la
colonisation est un processus qui est
irréversible c'est à dire que on parle
beaucoup de décoloniser le canada mais
il remarquer que les canadiens d'origine
européenne ne pouvant pas retourner en
europe
donc moi je pourrai pas retourner en
france je peux pas là on peut en irlande
parce que j'ai 10 ans est conseil le
bordel complet
il ya quelque chose d'irréversible dans
la colonisation on peut pas de
déboulonner christophe colomb ça ne sert
à rien de le déboulonner ce qu'on peut
faire c'est réparé c'est de créer de
nouveaux aménagements concessionnels
intentionnelle pour réparer un ace que
les défaites mais on ne pourra jamais
d'un revenir complètement en arrière
sinon c'est y ait quelque chose d'un peu
aussitôt pays dans le dans cette volonté
de décolonisation cette réconciliation
cette réparation et ce sont beaucoup de
mots mais enfin dans les faits ça donne
quoi
c'est la grande question effectivement
c'est tout le monde certains pour
morales main à tout le monde et pour la
réconciliation
mais le commun c'est je ne sais pas je
peux pas vous répondre c'est là
c'est ça c'est la question qui est sur
toutes les lèvres il suffira pas
vraiment de seulement proyer des fonds
publics à des communautés plus touché
l'argent ne règle pas tout donc il n'y a
pas de solution miracle à ce das et ses
traumatismes
c'est peut-être un peu triste de le dire
mais c'est la vérité
donc comment vont réparer ça comment
voir réussir à se réconcilier c'est sûr
que ça rend plus que des cérémonies des
dieux et gta mais c'est une question à
laquelle je répondais à laquelle
l'église at-elle clairement une part de
responsabilité officielle est ce que le
vatican devrait s'excuser est ce que
c'est une des pistes peut-être remarqué
on multiplie les excuses bons sont tout
aussi dans le fait beaucoup de
culpabiliser mme il y anime est aussi à
seul parce que ça devient très manichéen
le but c'est de réparer un c'est pas de
créer davantage de tensions entre les
personnes d'origine européenne ou les
énergies et c'est quand même une
tendance assez forte en amérique du nord
vous savez les tensions raciales sont
impurs et animé en partie par la gorge
moi c'est mon analyse donc vous faire
attention à ce que le pape dont doivent
s'excuser je sais pas exactement
et remarquez que c'est pas juste
l'église qui a donné que non plus qui
est impliquée a donc beaucoup d'églises
protestantes il d'ailleurs les
etats-unis se sont engagés à lancer une
enquête du même genre donc par effet
d'entraînement
on voit que c'est un aux siciliens sa
touche pas je suis catholique mais 5,5
sa touche le monde anglo saxon général
donc sa poche le protestantisme
donc est-ce que des représentants toutes
ces églises doivent s'excuser
peut-être peut-être une partie de la
solution je ne sais pas exactement
merci jérôme blanchet gravel d'avoir été
avec moi en direct sur arte france et
c'est la fin de cette émission prochain
point que sur l'actualité ce sera dans
quelques minutes à 22h
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés une découverte qui avaient été
faites par des gens qui travaillaient
sur les halles de kb identifié chez les
algues des protéines qui répondent à la
lumière et entraîne la formation d'un
courant électrique comme le font les
neurones et comme le font normalement
les cellules sensibles à la lumière dans
la rétine pas ce qu'il va dire qu'ils
voient imposer il distingue la lumière
il distingue quoi exactement par le
patient avec lapins par exemple de
reconnaître les passages protégés dans
la rue de détecter des objets différents
objets de petite taille de lentilles
plusieurs niveaux en passe de les
compter de les attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est une étape franchie
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe nous sommes chez
vox harry allons faire connaissance vous
avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors je
suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernières poches l'emporter en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylé fallu les français
ne savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire l'apologie ans et demi vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes ne bouleverse
nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à renault alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes pour rien
c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
tout est pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
à milan
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
m
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins il
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour l
assister à une guerre dans l'espace oui
la guerre est possible il ya de
multiples façons d'amener de rendre
inopérant effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]